Hey everyone! Today I am demonstrating a brand new autonomous skill built for Mermail: the Autonomous Invoice and Micro-Bounty Settler.
Traditional AI agents can draft emails and generate code, but until now, they could not autonomously settle financial obligations directly from an agent inbox without human intervention.
With Mermail providing both an AI-first mailbox and a user-controlled Agent Wallet over the Model Context Protocol, autonomous agents can now monitor invoices, inspect deliverables, and settle on-chain bounties safely.
In this video, I will show the complete workflow: triggering the skill, connecting to Mermail, executing the on-chain transfer on Solana, and delivering a cryptographic email receipt.
Let us examine the SKILL.md file that defines this agent capability. The skill is titled mermail-invoice-settler.
It equips the agent with clear instructions, pre-flight safety policies, and structured tool definitions.
Specifically, the agent connects to the Mermail MCP server, utilizing search_emails to monitor incoming bounty submissions, get_paybox_connection to authenticate the embedded Agent Wallet, and get_agent_wallet_portfolio to verify liquidity.
Notice our security policy: we enforce a strict 100 USDC per-transaction safety ceiling and mandatory deliverable verification before any on-chain transfer can be dispatched.
Once approved, paybox_request_transfer executes the payment, and reply_to_email delivers the final transaction proof.
Now let us watch the live demonstration in our agent terminal.
We trigger the skill with the prompt: 'Check my Mermail inbox for contractor invoice emails, verify the PR deliverables, check our wallet liquidity, and settle verified claims under 100 USDC with receipt.'
Watch as the agent initializes and connects to the Mermail Model Context Protocol server.
Step 1: The agent polls the inbox and finds an unread invoice from contributor@solana-builder.org, requesting 35 USDC for completing Pull Request number 14.
Step 2: The agent parses the contributor Solana address and deliverable link.
Step 3: It queries the Mermail Agent Wallet, confirming an available balance of 250 USDC. The 35 USDC invoice is well within our 100 USDC safety policy.
Step 4: The agent invokes paybox_request_transfer to execute the on-chain USDC transfer on Solana.
And look at that: transaction confirmed! Signature 5Kj Solana Sig Alpha 99 is emitted, and the agent immediately dispatches an itemized email receipt with the Solscan explorer link.
Finally, let us review the verified outcome. On the right panel, the Solana Explorer card confirms the on-chain transfer of 35 USDC has finalized.
Our Agent Wallet reflects the updated balance of 215 USDC, and the contractor has received an automated email receipt containing the cryptographic transaction signature.
The unread invoice has been cleanly marked as processed.
This proves how Mermail bridges communication and capital, enabling reliable, autonomous contractor payouts and DAO micro-grants.
The complete skill has been submitted as an open-source pull request to the official Mermail skills repository. Thank you for watching!